elle s'appelle déjà elle n'a que six ans
ça fait des semaines que son état se
détériore que c'est plaie s'infecte un
mal que les infirmières n'arrive pas à
soigner mais il aura fallu que ces
photos circulent sur les médias sociaux
pour que la petite soit enfin évacué
vers un hôpital ce matin aux frais du
gouvernement fédéral
si seulement son cas était unique le
petit i go à quatre mois lui aussi à la
peau irritée et même des lésions infecté
il est parti dimanche d'urgence à bord
d'un avion médicalisé avec un autre bébé
jenayah cinq mois couverte de plaies de
la tête aux pieds
c'est son oncle derek steven l'ancien
chef de la première nation de casser
show one qui a organisé et payé pour
leur évacuation
désespéré c'est lui qui a publié ces
photos pour qu'ottawa intervienne sur le
champ et photos de ses enfants sont
troublantes et choquantes comme beaucoup
d'autres le député de la région chaliand
gay soupçonne la mauvaise qualité de
l'eau qui a toujours été une malédiction
pour cette petite communauté isolée du
nord de l'ontario
la ministre de la santé confirme qu'une
équipe médicale est envoyée pour
enquêter sur le terrain dans cette
réserve
pauvre et délabré où rien ne semble
avoir changé dans les dix dernières
années qu'à ses choix n'est devenue
tristement célèbre en 2005 qu'en plus la
moitié de la population a dû être
évacués en pleine crise de l'eau
contaminée qui causait des problèmes de
santé graves y compris des problèmes de
peau qui malgré plusieurs ententes avec
le gouvernement libéral puis
conservateur
les nombreux problèmes de la réserve
inondations insalubrité aux contaminés
n'ont jamais été réglé
tamara on apprend ce soir qu'il ya des
dizaines d'autres enfants qui sont sur
le point d'être évacués en fait leur nom
de 6,9 économique augmente
oui la liste augmente une vingtaine au
total qui a réussi depuis 24 heures les
parents ce manifeste et publie les uns
après les autres de rendre des photos de
leur petit des problèmes de peau se
plaignent que les services de santé sur
place ne sont pas à la hauteur et des
parents qui ont des dix bals donnés de
bain ou bep bep par jour ça devrait
régler le problème si cellou qui sans qu
on a de sérieux problèmes ça fait autre
chose ça paie des problèmes de
moisissures d'insalubrité moi j'y suis
allé pendant l'évacuation il ya onze ans
que ce choix de passer du temps c'est la
misère il ya des conditions de vie
extrêmement difficiles vous l'avez vu
donc ottawa a décidé d'intervenir
d'urgence aujourd'hui envoyer une équipe
de trois médecins qui vont aller frapper
aux portes de tous les résidents sont
presque 2000 pour voir qu'il ya des
problèmes et quelle est la source
surtout bon évidemment demain c'est jour
de budget est ce qu'on s'attend à ce
qu'il dit sommes importantes pour
justement pallier à ces problèmes
criants
oui qui sont partout au canada dans les
réserves la réponse est oui c'était une
des promesses central du gouvernement
trudeau quand il a fait campagne
on s'attend donc à des sommes
substantielles de l'argent neuf comme on
dit d'abord pour l'éducation des
premières nations mais pour
particulièrement les problèmes d'eau
potable justin trudeau à premier il le
fait plusieurs fois d'éliminer d'ici
cinq ans tous les avertissements de
faire bouillir l'eau qui allie ziskin
canada sur les réserves y en a des
centaines et des centaines donc faudra
voir combien sera dirigée dans les
problèmes sanitaires demain
dans le budget ils savent au delà de
remplacer les infrastructures vous faire
de l'information souvent le problème
c'est que les opérateurs de ces usines
de traitement d'eau sont incompétents
pour citer la ministre des affaires
autochtones
elle disait la semaine dernière si on
est capable canada de rapatrier
d'urgence en quelques mois 25 mille
réfugiés syriens
on doit être capable de fournir de l'eau
potable à tous les canadiens devraient
en tout cas merci beaucoup de m'avoir